so the phillies took day one they find
themselves now at the 500 mark a half
game behind the giants for the seventh
spot but more importantly the marlins
are playing right now against washington
that game's in the bottom of the seventh
inning if the phillies if the marlins
wind up losing that game the phillies
will creep even closer
to the miami marlins for the second spot
in the postseason
facing david hale
the veteran right-hander
who has uh made four appearances for the
phillies
[Music]
and
is basically a long man
for most of his career has started
before it's not like it's new to him
but joe girardi wasn't sure who he was
going to go with so he goes with his
longman which is traditionally what you
do when you have to use the spot starts
the shed hitting 318 he was over three
in game one with a strikeout
now to right field moniak
toward the corner that's slicing away
from him it's off the wall he plays it
well the throw goes to second
and the shed is there
well that's the approach the blue jays
had when they're swinging the bats well
going the opposite field up the middle
there and both staying back on that
breaking ball and hits it off the fence
in right field
ross tripling will
make the start it'll be his fifth career
start against the phillies
he's actually pitched pretty well here
in this ballpark
and he is 1-0
in four career starts against
philadelphia bryce harper in back
and lying in the left center that's a
base hit
richik will cut it off harper's thinking
too
the throw the tag they got him
randall grichik throws out bryce harper
at second base
see if dede can cut through the wind
right here on a two out homer
in the air to right field going back on
it is hernandez it's over his head off
the base of the scoreboard the phillies
will take the lead again dede gregorius
comes through in the first inning
an rbi single one-nothing bills
not only for him but also for the
organization
rolls over on one to third richik does
bohm's throw was high and he got to the
bag
5-3 on the put out good job by jay bruce
kritchik wasn't really running that hard
really nice job by jay bruce
and a swinging miss strippling will get
quinn one down
and strippling with the back-to-back
strikeouts as he gets moniak two down
there's rafael marchand the
catcher for the phillies
and stripling strikes out three batters
in a row after the lead-off walk to
kingery and the phillies are gone at the
bottom of the second two away
[Applause]
chad turned himself into a good lady guy
too dd trying to throw buchet out and he
does 6-3 on the put out 29 pitches in
three innings
for david hale andrew mccutchen will
start it off again
in the air to right field that's well
hit going back on it is hernandez it is
gone opposite field home run for andrew
mccutchen number eight for catch
and the phillies lead at two nothing
oscar hernandez steps in
to oscar hits it down the left field
line will it stay fair
it will
he's back tay oscar hernandez with his
15th home run of the season and the blue
jays are on the board i think there's
one down here in the fourth inning in
the batteries vladimir guerrero jr
a breaking ball grounded to the left of
gregorius it'll sneak through into
center and gritchik's going to come
around to score on the play as the jays
tie the game
and now it's santiago espinal who will
come to the plate
he did and he lines it into left center
a base hit guerrero had to wait to see
if it would get through he is still
making the turn and heading for home
throw comes into second and the blue
jays have the lead and now it's left up
to biggio
viscio with a base hit to cash in a
couple of runs
what a big two-out base hit for cabin
biggio and the blue jays now lead five
to two
here's money act
there's a line drive based in it to
right field money first major league hit
and it moves kingry up to second base
that was a sweet swing day what the tmac
it is an exciting feeling to get that
first knock here's marshawn
a high fly ball to deep right field
hernandez going back toward the wall it
is gone
raphael marchand
a three-run home run he's never hit one
professionally until now
it's a five-five game
now they don't have his picture just yet
on a cutout so
that's what they've decided to put up
just to remind them rudders around the
corners nobody out in the blue jays
knocking on the door
and grichik drives the ball well hit to
left it will be caught by mccutchen
tagging and coming in to score on the
play is goriel and the sac fly gives the
blue jays the lead it's three and two
runners go and it's inside ball four to
force in a run
and harper's the hitter with two outs
out to center field that's well hit
going back on it is gretchen still going
back it is off the wall two runs will
score and harper to second base sliding
it's a two run double the ball game is
tied at seven he is definitely back
alec balm the hitter
and boom hits it to the right side it
gets past guerrero nobody's covering
first the throw is off the glove here
comes harper he kept on coming he'll
score and the phillies take the lead
eight to seven it's a base hit for alec
balm
so two walks with two outs
and it brings cabin vigil to the plate
and a line drive out to center field
roman quinn comes in and he makes the
catch and the phillies have swept out
the blue jays